so i i've been working for cern and
atsun for the past 18 19 years now
it's never boring the the job is
different every day it's terrible you
don't want to come here no no no no i
i'm just selfish it's just the world's
greatest place to work
you you know we wake up in the morning
and you've got these
mountains in the background that most
people have never heard of actually
called the azura mountains they're
actually quite famous they're called
they gave their name to the jurassic
period that everybody has heard of
because a lot of fossils were found up
there of dinosaurs so here you've got
like pre-history from
tens of millions of years ago
just on your doorstep but then really on
your doorstep what we're doing here at
cern
is we're going back in time as far as
you can possibly go to nearly 14 billion
years you have this place a laboratory
that's got thousands of people who are
from all over the planet who are all
different one way or the other they're
all smarter than i am it's a little
annoying
but it's great there's no better
environment to live in an environment
where people are smarter than you and
you're surrounded by brilliant people
and they're all here uh on their own
accord because they want to be a part of
something they want to discover
something and so
it's just it's just a positive and
outstanding atmosphere so getting up in
the morning and thinking that you're
going to make some contribution to
understanding what the universe was like
then why it's like it is now and where
it's going
is you know quite a motivator in itself
so
it's never really boring you do
something different every day but i
imagine when you're around a lot of
alpha people competitive people the top
people in the world which is what cern
attracts
is it good being surrounded by such
competitive driven people all the time i
imagine it could it could
it could grind you into the ground well
just just those who uh don't understand
that i'm right okay that's those are the
only ones i have a problem with actually
it's it's the most important part of
science uh the most important part of
science is the fact that you have all
these other people and on atlas we have
three thousand people we all have a
chance to look at an analysis each one
and say there's a problem with that
you're not doing this this or this and
this
each analysis each bit of of data each
paper that we put out there in the world
has survived this and that means
that it's
true okay that means that it's been peer
reviewed and by the smartest people and
and we do disagree we do have fights and
we argue about whether we're doing this
right and with what we saw is what we're
saying it is
it has to survive that and that's
important indeed to the outside it may
seem as if we're just a bunch of
physicists sitting in an ivory tower and
all we do all day is think about things
and do stuff related to particle physics
that's really not the reality there's a
whole
world
outside that people are exploring in
music in theater and everything you can
possibly imagine skiing of course just
up on the mountains
so it
we're normal people
no you you have to be lucky i think i
think i was lucky uh i think that you
know you have to study hard and go into
physics but you know if you do go into
physics for example uh the chances are
these days one of the biggest fields is
particle physics and if you go into
particle physics this is the place a lot
of of my colleagues i've seen them all
around the planet over the years
we most of us have ended up here one
time or another because this is really
the biggest laboratory for particle
physics so my route
to cern was a very traditional one if
you like so i did a
my a levels in the uk
and including physics and maths of
course went on to do a
bsc in physics imperial college in
london and did a
postgraduate degree at imperial college
and then came here as a fellow
and then a staff member so it's a very
traditional way of doing it but we we
also take
people as young as 15 16
for like a week's work experience
occasionally to follow a physicist or an
engineer around and get their hands
dirty and see what we really do
we have programs for older students and
sort of 18
19 years old where they can spend a
couple of weeks here there are also
plenty of people who are engineers or
technicians who come over here and and
they're always looking for good people
so you can always apply for jobs there
and in addition there's a lot of
programs to bring interns and to bring
students so there's a lot of even
undergraduate students who come here and
contribute for a short period of time
but generally people's first experiences
long term will be after they've done a
couple of years of an undergraduate
degree normally in physics but also
computing electronics
and so on
and then come here as a summer student
which is again something i did as well
and spend a couple of months working on
a real research project so different
ways of getting here depends what you
want to do
it's noisy
it's
it's like if you've been on a on a ship
on um
you know across across the english
channel or something and you're on
you're on the the hum of the engines
constantly the hadron color limiter
and then within that you've got the the
inner detector and the pipe itself so
literally it's deep within that is where
all where it's all going on where it's
all kicking off